chanting for the Kings well-being after
seven decades on the throne king bumi
pond is the only king most Thais have
ever known and even though the King has
been in hospital for many years the
latest news about his condition comes as
a shock to many here at siriraj hospital
in the heart of Bangkok King Bumi pond
is being treated for his illnesses in
fact it is here he spent much of the
last few years and especially at times
like these this is the place where
people come to pray for his health
people here feel it is important to be
close to their king now more than ever
to cheer him up yes in the first place
that I've heard not very good news and I
like to yeah in the bed bad case and
scenario just say goodbye to him cool
collected a lot from turning up in no
time hello the king is our role model we
try to follow his example he loves and
cares about the people indiscriminately
every ties should know about his
devotion okay lover I personally would
do and give anything for him to recover
oh hai tanhai papa to one God on his own
whoo-hoo-hoo anyone I pray for the King
to have a long life hook now he's
revered by ties and I want him to be
with us for a long time with alanna
Hapgood I don't want him to be sick and
I don't want his condition to get worse
when he have ties are keeping up hope
that their king will recover yet again
like so many times in the past but some
also seem to feel that this time they
might have to pray harder than ever
before